welcome back to cmake today we're going
to be looking at C Dash now this is the
second part of C test which was the
previous episode from months ago
and we're just gonna pick up from there
and we're gonna add C Dash into the mix
and I'm going to talk to you about that
and what it is and basically all the
things I learned while getting this set
up because there are definitely some
things that you should know and this
will probably save you quite a bit of
time I was definitely left with a lot of
questions when trying to figure this out
I didn't really find good answers to
them other than well I eventually
figured them out so hopefully I can save
you a little bit of the misery and by
making this video alright so let's get
into it let's open this project and sail
away
all right so while we're at it we're
gonna take just a little bit of time now
I'm using a different editor now just to
correct some syntax things here and
there as we go so let's uh let me bring
this over here our solution Explorer so
you guys can see it as well solution
Explorer okay
so this is gonna Auto uh do its thing
you can do that from Visual Studio by
adding editing your cmake settings but I
have it set to Auto configure anytime I
make a save to a cmake file so it just
does this thing you can do that manually
if that bugs you if you're making a lot
of changes and it's constantly uh doing
this but that's up to you all right so
what here we're looking at is the test C
major and the math one I've got several
tests
C makes so I went ahead and did made a
few changes when I Was preparing this
video
um just some minor things like I just
need to do a little trust thing here
we want to update our git ignore and
stuff too because now that we're doing
some testing
apparently my git ignore doesn't have
dot vs in it so it's trying to commit a
few too many things to GitHub so we'll
just have to sort that out a little bit
there should be a got me s in here no
okay well we're gonna add dot vs and
that should cut off
trying to commit a bunch of that stuff
all right so it looks a little better
so uh I want to just walk through a few
of these changes it shouldn't be
anything major I think it's mostly
syntax stuff like what I even do here
change the spacing I don't okay uh put
pragma once on the headers that's a good
idea so a little a few little fixes came
in here and just some some spacing
issues it looks like straighten that out
in the tester
and uh you know for the math one is the
math test I want to make sure we link
the right stuff okay here's the biggest
change I think all right I think the
main thing I did was I commented out the
fine glue stuff because I'm I'm gutting
the graphic stuff out of this and it's
just not really
it's just going beyond the scope of
cmake so uh yeah we're gonna just delete
the graphics tester that's gonna be
Legacy stuff I was just using it as an
example uh we're probably gonna get rid
of this external stuff so thing about
this let me show it on GitHub well we've
got this added as a sub module glfw as a
sub module now I was just doing that as
an example but I'm just going to go
ahead and remove it now and now this is
totally separate from c-test and C Dash
but it is important to be able to know
how to remove sub modules
so we are going to go over that it's
important to know that just like you
know I could delete this external
but it's still gonna it's not gonna get
rid of the reference that's through a
git setting so let's address that oh
this is one of those things that I find
nearly impossible to fully remember so I
pretty much always have to Google this
here are some general steps
um there's a gist there's a stack
Overflow let's look at this gist I think
I have used this one before okay delete
the relevant section from the get
modules file
stage the git module changes delete the
relevant section from git config
all right and then we got to run some
stuff so let's delete the relevant
section from get module file now we'll
find get modules here on the root
directory there it is
let me just delete the whole thing hit
save now it says stage to get modules
changes
so let's go over to get changes however
you're doing gits fine and let's find
git modules and it's just stage we don't
have to like fully commit to stage and
then delete the relevant section of
git.config so go back to our solution
find our
get config now you might not see this
easily because it might be in a hidden
folder if so you just need to open it in
your file explorer or you know through
your terminal however you want to do
it's fine but through your file explorer
Let's see we should see
like a DOT get it might be hidden you
might have to go view hidden items here
so if you don't see it that might be why
all right and then you want to go in
here find that config there it is make
sure that's the right one yep
there it is dot git config
and it says delete the relevant section
so we're going to open this with the
visual studio code here so let's delete
this whole sub module section press save
here
and we should be good
and now let's make sure we do the next
part right we need to run a command git
RM
get remove dash dash cached and then
path to the sub module so for us it's
going to be external jlfw all right so
let's bring up the terminal and we can
do it here developer Powershell I can
hit control tilde to bring that up if
you don't see it out so get Dash RM
dash dash cast and then the path so the
path is external slash glfw and let's
see if that does okay we got to do
remove without the dash in front of it
all right very good
let's go on to the next step and then do
an actual remove of the git sub modules
so we'll do that RM Dash RF for
recursive and force and same directory
actually we're just going to do this
entire external so I'm not even going to
go deeper into that directory just like
that should be fine
um
we are in a developer Powershell not in
Linux so it is a little different for us
uh yeah I guess we just gotta delete it
manually here so let's go back to our
folder look for
you know I know I'm a little off topic
here but I just want to show everything
I'm doing
uh so we will get to this C Dash but you
know just a few configurations first all
right well apparently in modules path to
sub module so we should have it in here
yeah so we want to delete this as well
now
um if you're on Linux you're going to
use the RM I forgot to get when I did
the command so it should be you know
something like dot get slash like that
and then modules however
um yeah RM just doesn't work in this
Powershell anyway so that's why I had to
go and delete it manually okay now it's
gone there's nothing in modules and
last thing we just want to basically
commit these changes
and we should be good to go and we
should be able to delete this now as
well so let's delete the external go to
our stage changes and uh I think I'm
just going to do a full commit here and
see if that's good enough to commit
everything
move sub module and clean up so I'm just
doing this straight to master
just as a
just as a way of well I'll explain more
later but basically to use C Dash
properly you need to be committed and
pushed and all that stuff so it's got
one outgoing looks like it only wants to
pull here created locally okay I've got
a little thing to sort out okay so we
got uh we got that sorted out I
basically just had to uh relaunch this
app for its little GitHub helper to pick
up that I could push I needed I don't
know needed to validate my credentials
or something all right so we can close
all this stuff from the cleanup
okay now I think we are properly
prepared to go to C Dash I know a little
late in the video but we've got
everything straightened out I had to get
that sub module removed I didn't have to
but the thing is I've got a graphics
tutorial I've got an opengl tutorial so
if you want to see more of the graphic
stuff check that out so your top level C
mate now we have
a cmake minimum required I'm going to go
ahead and bump this up to 3.15 just
because I tend to use features up to 15
and I think we're going to get to that
now another thing you're supposed to do
with these cmake files is you should at
least have this version in all your
little Sub C makes so we're going to go
ahead and get that corrected as well uh
yeah just kind of adheres to some better
standards that way you know because like
this test file or any of these files in
theory you should be able to take them
to some other project so you want to at
least know the minimum required and if
they're sub projects you probably need
to declare a new project I don't know
we're not going to get into that I don't
want to get too sidetracked but at least
got to get some of this cleanup done see
we've got an option for use Adder that's
fine we've got an option for test Adder
you know when you run C making turn
these on or off they're going to default
on if you don't say so if we do test
Adder
why do I have
test adder in two different places now
this should be used okay so I have a
little bug here I don't think anyone
ever caught pretty sure this one should
just be if you use Adder add the
subdirectory of the adder and add up to
the live so yeah okay so I had a little
bug there that's
that's good but here's the big thing if
we're testing the adder we're going to
enable testing and add the
subdirectories for tests so that's
enough to get the test going and you do
have to have this enable testing on your
top level cmake okay keep that in mind
enable testing has to be on the top
level cmake if you're using visual
studio like I am it's not going to show
you the test results unless you have it
on the top level that's someone actually
pointed out out in the comments so I
appreciate that comment uh you were
right about that so if I go to my test
Explorer
uh here just on visual studio and this
is the default one that comes with it
you can find it too by going to I
believe wind or one of these test test
Explorer yeah and there it is now it
wants like a namespace in a class we
don't have any here but we can make them
real quick but it does have math test
one through four and those are added
right
here you know through sub several
subdirectory ads
now this uh we don't need this if we've
already got an if that takes care of
that earlier on we're just double
checking at that point so we'll just
remove that because it's if it's adding
this file
you know we've already got some uh
checks here to make sure that's going
right all right so
that adds this one this one adds another
subdirectory here and it can just kind
of Cascades down we got our math test
now to name space these like it says no
namespace here I know it's hard to read
probably no class you just put dots in
here so we would do like
namespace math class Adder test one
through four okay so now when we
ReDiscover go back to our test Explorer
and hit find all
we should see that it's now in math
adder
and then there's all the tests so you
can name space class like that
to get them sorted out right here okay
and that that should be good okay now
let's get to the super fun parts so
we're running our test here you know
normally if you don't have this window
and you just want to run C test you just
do it from your developer shell from
your terminal
uh here it is you know you just want to
be in the directory of your repo and
just type in c-test and it'll say no
config found okay so actually you need
to do this in the binary directory so
we're probably going to be an out slash
build we might do this build we're going
to be an x64 uh looks like we're in
release currently now you run C test
and there you go so you got to be in
your build directory when you run this
and you know we could make a script to
do that or something but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna go all that and as you can
see we pass them all these are very
simple we're just adding two numbers
together but hey a test is a test okay
so now here comes the tricky part well
you know most of this has been for view
clean up and I know it's been a bit
lengthy but it's important to make sure
you know where we're at
otherwise the following stuff won't make
sense okay so we want to add C Dash all
right so what is C Dash what the heck is
it sounds like another buzzword and it
is I'll explain C Dash here all right so
I've got it pulled up on cmake's website
and I'm just going to go over the
highlights here as I've already kind of
read through all of this and you know
you can if you want but it's basically a
lot of stuff that says C Dash is a
results dashboard so when you run your
tests uh you can have a history of your
results and that's all this is it's just
a history of your previous runs
so there's a lot to this you know and
they you know it goes to further
analysis if you can get uh continuous
testing you know this is where the
nightly experimental continuous coverage
Dynamic analysis A lot of that stuff
grows from from this
uh dashboard and just keeping track of
the results on a regular basis
so they talk about adding support and
okay so C Dash if I understand correctly
is open source and you can go download
your own copy of C Dash and you can go
run it on your own server if you want
you don't have to use their website you
can run your own server so that's kind
of I think that's more important for big
companies and stuff that want to have
their own internal testing and stuff
like that you can still use C Dash but
there's also a website and it's just my
cdash.org so we are going to head over
there shortly so we will need to but
let's uh let's look at client setup
because this is the part that we're
going to have to do is the client setup
I'm going to explain this in detail as
we go because there were definitely a
few pitfalls here that took up a bit of
my time and hopefully I can save you
from that we have to include
c-test
now c-test
is not already included we have include
where we have enable testing and we have
subdirectories added and stuff but
there's no include c-test and what does
include do do you guys remember it
basically just brings in header files so
uh if testing we're going to enable
testing we're going to add subdirectory
test and we're also going to go include
C test
now this includes c-test is going to
perform some lookups it's going to look
for files in your directory and what
it's going to is what it's going to do
and mainly it's going to look for like a
c test
config.cmake if it finds a c-test
config.cmake that's like tacked on the
end automatically of this include you
just don't see it here I know that's so
confusing that actually had me hung up
for a bit so just keep that in mind
we're just looking for an actual file
and it's already putting this on the end
of it without you knowing it necessarily
unless you've studied cmake and time so
hopefully that clears it up so it's
going to look for a c-test file they
don't have a c-test file we have to go
set one up and that's where we go to the
dashboard so let's head on back over
there and I'm just going to click this
link with middle click so it opens in a
new tab
and here we have C Dash I know not the
prettiest of websites I'm going to go
ahead and full screen it sorry for the
brightness but you'll see you know you
probably have to log in I'm already
logged in so I have a my C Dash up here
and a log out all these projects and
dashboards don't worry about them
they're just other people's stuff I have
no idea why they put them up front like
this you tell me
so they start a new project is
intuitively all the way at the bottom
when you go to your my projects page all
right here Administration right at the
bottom start a new project so that's
what you need to do for the first time
give it a name
uh we're gonna call this well we're just
going to name it after our repo here so
let's just go to our top level C make
and grab that and there's some
information we can put in here we can
put in a home URL bug tracker URL so
these are essentially uh let's see if we
go to this repo I'll just uh put it up
on a side screen here if it'll let me
there we go we go to our repo
we've got our repo here can be the home
URL for now unless your thing has a web
page bug tracker we're gonna put our
issues page
and if you have this other stuff you can
fill it out but I don't believe I have
any for this one and it asks if you want
a public dashboard which means only
accept submissions bearing a valid auth
token I'm not 100 sure on these I think
I'm just going to leave it default in
Next Step you can select a logo if you
want you just gotta follow their guide
I'm not going to do that in this case
repository I'm guessing in this case
it's going to be the same as our home
URL we're just going to use the repo
again repository viewer type so there's
a bunch of different repository viewers
we're just going to use GitHub here
plain old GitHub if you're using
something else there's a bunch there
and now we have
another repository length same thing
again now this repository is an actual
important one because this is for the
server stuff and it wants a branch too
now this is old style I've still got uh
just the master Branch I never went any
further with this one so we would just
put that very interesting in here this
is only
single Branch repo and we have a
username and password that it can cache
but we are not going to do that so just
leave those blank and that should be
good enough so these are these are the
main important ones so far is this
repository and which branch next tab is
a testing tab we're going to leave this
all default
and we have an email coverage email
submission failures sure why not set
this up as you like and then a little
miscellaneous you can set up this as you
like too I'm not going to do anything
here and it is complete we can now go to
our C Dash project and there's no builds
for Olas very good so what we want to do
at this point is we want to get our
config file all of this creating the
project so we can snag that config file
so go to settings
I believe it's project and in here you
will find under miscellaneous a c-test
config.cmake now this is a very elusive
file it looks like you can click it and
download it you can click it and open it
in this PHP thing and it tells you what
to do but if you hit Ctrl s to save it
you end up with this dot PHP file and
it's not really what you want so you can
save it and then rename the file that
works or you can just copy all of this
and then we'll go back to visual studio
we'll bring the dashboard back in a
second so you want to go to your top
level cmake uh wherever it is make sure
yeah there's the include C test this is
what is going to look for this config
file so we want to let's just go to our
top level of our project here add new
file and we're going to put in c-test
Big Dot CMC or if you save the file it
might be some dot PHP thing rename it to
this exactly paste in all that stuff
get rid of the comments if you want I'm
just going to leave them for now but the
main thing is
that you set all of this stuff but
basically you'll see that you got a
project name you got a nightly start
time the drop method https is default
here but there's other stuff that you'll
see in the documentation
um as far as setting up your own servers
and stuff there's the drop site it's
just my cdash and the location is the
submit to project drop site C Dash true
just needs to be set and that's that's
it so once that's all set up it knows
where to push our results now the next
thing we want to do here is basically
push to master all right so this is
super important if I run C test
as experimental right now uh as this
next step
let's see I'll bring the documentation
back over in the client setup
we did the include okay we got this all
sorted out um we just finished the
include
next thing to do was just you know we've
already got tests we can add more if we
want but we basically want to run this
c-test Dash D and then with some
dashboard entry like experimental but if
you do this be warned it doesn't say
this anywhere here and they don't tell
you if you do this it discards all your
changes on your repo that you've been
making with Git and pools the latest so
you will lose your changes if you just
go type this
so uh
I don't know why they don't maybe they
did mention it I missed it but they
should really mention that because I
like lost a lot of changes doing that
once and it was uh kind of annoying okay
looks like this is good now
so we just basically just want to commit
these changes
um is my point otherwise we're going to
lose what we got but first let's just
make sure everything runs got some
initialization warnings there
math test ran and did nothing let's try
the install yeah if we go look at math
test I believe it wants some kind of
argument yeah
otherwise returns negative one
what is this formatting space tab here
oh my goodness all right so we're just
going to go to git and we've got our
changes here we've got a little C test
config in here we've got a
uh some changes to the cmake
uh I think I'm just going to commit all
these here in a second yeah we're just
going to do it even though there's
multiple things going on here I'm just
going to do it as one commit CTS okay
and then we're going to push
I'm going to use the sink and we are
syncing to master right to GitHub
servers resolved
success okay so now that this is Success
we can go to our terminal and we are
already currently path to where we want
and we're on our release build we can
now run C tests all right now let's just
observe something I'm going to move some
of this stuff I want to get our
dashboard back over here hit back on
this file here
let's go to dashboard
and this is our dashboard there's
nothing here it's just nice and blank
okay but you'll see once I run this
c-tash data ctask the c-test Dash D
experimental and if you want to make
sure you don't typo this copy paste
and we'll give it a run looks like it
went through everything it created a new
tag it had some errors and warnings when
building so we might look at those
performed coverage
cannot find coverage files ignoring
requests so that's another thing we'll
we might talk about at some point
coverage
and it submitted files there were errors
while running C test okay so let's see
if our dashboard updated yes it did
here's our dashboard it looks like we've
got a whole bunch of warnings here
and some errors
that we could look at and we've got our
warnings from double to float we saw
those natively but we didn't see any of
these so this has given us some insights
but ultimately you've got the meat and
potatoes of this
at this point that's how you upload
tests you run some kind of thing I would
highly recommend going over this page
it's got stuff that I can't include in
this episode
but you can do a lot with this we have
essentially completed the hello world
and got it initialized so you should be
able to
take off from here with it
and if there's a lot of like the same
question or something maybe we can do a
part two but otherwise I'll move on
all right so I'm going to address these
first I'm going to look for some hints
here from these
uh warnings here we got a fatal error
three unresolved externals let's see the
tester object has external symbol a to F
referenced in Main and FTL used now a to
F should be in one of the headers I
think unresolved external main CRT step
startup okay
okay so if I'm understanding this
warning correctly uh it's our a2f a2f is
how we're turning our arguments into
float values but this returns a double A
TF returns a double
so we're adding those together and then
saving it as a float which is implicit
and uh casting to a larger type or
casting to a shorter type you know we're
going from this large double to a
smaller float
so what happens there you know that's
what's confusing and same same here with
this ad
um we're actually taking in doubles this
thing is returning a double
but when we call our add function it's
only floats so that's uh not exactly
ideal that's probably what all these
warnings and errors are from and our
thanks to our tests we actually caught
that very very quickly all right because
if we like look at a to F let me just
bring this over real quick you know this
is off the scope of
uh C Dash and C test but you know it's
an example of how it kind of goes back
into your flow here's what uh
8f will take it'll take any of these and
you can get
you know just a great way to get dumpers
basically it's from C standard lab so
yeah that's probably fine but I think
because we're running in 64 it wants
doubles I think I'm not 100 on that but
there's a couple things we could do we
could just add it here we could add a
double version
we could do that and we just need to
declare it in the header here and that
should clear up some of the stuff and
when we go back to our tester
um we could probably just Auto these
and Autos should understand because
everything's double here this ad is
going to now call the the double version
of it rather than implicitly calling the
float one and this just should be two
doubles added together you get the value
so these Autos should both deduce to
double we could specify double in here
and that'd be fine too let's just let's
just put that let's not confuse people
with auto so now when we do our rebuild
here let's see what happens no warnings
this time let's go ahead and
hit the math test
um actually let's just do the test test
Explorer if you can't find it hit the
Run
and it seems to pass all our basic tests
there so now let's say we add overload
more doubles all right let's go ahead
and put that in there and we'll sync
that and now remember if you want to run
C test you got to do this push and sync
thing first it's got to know your
changes were committed so that's why
we're doing that let's go back to our
developer Powershell we're still on the
output director here so we should just
be able to run our c-test experimental
again and see what we get this time
and this time it passed and didn't have
any errors so let's go look at that on
the dashboard here we are back to our
dashboard let's hit actual dashboard
here and we've got a couple warnings uh
there's uh there's one you know with all
the before we fixed everything before we
fix that double problem
there's all those warnings and then we
ran it again this time we got four pass
just now
so you can get these over time and you
know you can make you can do stuff with
your own data hope you've enjoyed this
video on C Dash and how to get it going
and its usefulness and how to kind of
start integrating it into your flow as
we've slightly done here
now sure I would do a Lot of Things
Different Here If This Were a real
project so you know like we could
template this ad to handle integers and
stuff it doesn't even handle integers
but that's besides the point we're just
you know
sample project stuff we're going to
close this we're going to say goodbye
we're going to thank the patrons and the
supporters and viewers like you good
luck I know peace